people of the internet retro raconteur
here your guide to family-friendly
content in the world of video games now
in today's video we're gonna be jumping
back into Luigi's Mansion 3 we're on
floor 10 which is called the tomb sweets
this game is insane with the amount of
variety that it has just keeps getting
better and better and better and I hope
you guys enjoy these videos Luigi still
very uncomfortable oh my good
it's just fire did you come down come
down you're good dude you're good he's
still very uncomfortable with this whole
situation despite the previous Luigi's
Mansion games I mean he should kind of
be a pro at this ghost hunting thing
right now oh you see that
whoa trap door hello
trap door justjust like a trap in the
center of the room ok so you can't step
on that or if you do you're gonna get
shot by snake statues gotta watch out
for those snake statues
alright so you know what we'll use go
gooey G for this
we'll have qyg hold it right here where
you go now regularly we'd you you just
walk on over yep pick it up we got this
we got this under control bin goodbye
DGP for your services we're gonna press
on through these doors right here whoa
[Music]
am I actually outside now this is
actually crazy you could suck up all the
sand whoa
[Music]
get him in there - get him in there - I
feel like something's kind of telling me
there's gonna be a boss fight here guys
now this is interesting like you see how
the camera kind of pulls back when I get
this one I shoot at it that wow that was
weak hey scoober what's up I know right
I just like part of me wants to know
what happens what happens if I go and
suck up all this sand in it would take
me a while to get this whole room so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna walk
up here see if there's anything we can
interact with right here before doing
anything else okay I think I gotta shoot
that ball up there like when I try to
aim higher than that right there nothing
happens okay so maybe I was maybe I was
wrong maybe it's not this ball oh we've
got the magic lamp
wait what I feel like okay I feel like
the magic lamp is definitely gonna play
a part in this forget it
oh my goodness you serious that's all a
magic lamp gives me money where's the
genie
come on man I was so pumped to see a
genie pop out of that lamp oh oh hold on
hold on though yeah not a genie not a
genie
but I'll take it I knew there had to be
something more to them okay let me get
the angle on it okay so right there and
okay up from there directly up from
there
Haupt the beach ball it was literally a
beach ball dude not what we thought but
we did indeed solve the mystery of the
beach ball and it did give us a little
achievement I should say even though
it's a Nintendo game cutscene yeah
Wow
[Music]
as all you scoobert you called that one
you call that an you mention the idea of
the mound oh no not so fast not so fast
what stun you with the light oh he
blocked it alright so first we probably
got a unraveling maybe can we unravel
you can we remove your wrappings pulling
our ghost inside chant oh yeah that's
what we got to do we just got to get
really close to him see I didn't go in
close enough been around now you're
gonna reveal them
well that was a few ghosts yeah I guess
the purple one in there too come on over
here
come on over here dude where you going
okay so that was way too much weight I
almost think I need to take two of them
off leave the sand yeah let's go now we
have to do it again aren't we oh oh
great hey where's that one that one is
the third one honestly like what if I
just take this off and just have the
sand
[Music]
look at that oh yeah we're good here
wait wait maybe maybe tell me man the
variety of this game
they just keep it going oh man this is
weird all right it's sucking my life
away
[Music]
gotta find more of those little orbs
dude come on all its different shapes I
just got lucky with that first one there
it is
- sneaky sneaky on me like that guys if
this your first time checking off the
stream thank you so much for stopping by
tonight hope you all are enjoying your
Monday evening if you have any questions
feel free to jump in the chat ask if you
just prefer to sit back relax and enjoy
the stream that is totally fine as well
we are a family friendly stream we do
this every Monday Wednesday and a Friday
right here at twitch.tv slash Metro I
can tour my friends and there we go all
right we called it said there's gonna be
a boss fight in this room it's just too
big of an area and there's a massive
snake sculpture on the side all there
she is Manor all right guys
we gotta figure out what to do here
Jeannie I want my three wishes please oh
wow
[Music]
okay they were kind of stunned for a
little bit so I don't know if I'm
supposed to run up and I tried to run up
and stun them nothing happened yes all
right come on snakes come on out of
there
[Music]
all right snakes go on snake snakes I
don't know what did I do
[Music]
whoo I thought it had to do with getting
rid of all of snakes
all right there she is okay so what yes
there we go dude
[Music]
alright 186 so we're gonna we're gonna
do that three times
[Music]
back up back up why why were they not
storm to that time why were they not
stunned away
[Music]
runner
they're gonna have to do one more time
yes at least we did get one heart so
we're not stuck at 39 hell oh look at
that listen to that triumphant music
listen to the triumphant music you know
what lady get that smirk off your face
not today
oh no it's the hand can I push it away
wait what are you supposed to do about
the hand
there's multiple words now no what are
you talking about no let's say not the
hands hey I can't do anything you the
hands are just gonna kill me
oh I bet you can stun them mm but it did
give me a heart come on get over here
get over here we go very Luigi you're
slow no way dude no way what go ahead do
you think snakes no no no why do they
not get stored anymore do not get
stunned at all anymore oh my gosh we
have 19 hp guys you have 19 HP yes
we gotta dodge this and laughter
[Music]
19 help 19 house oh man let's go that
was cool I'm a knight I enjoyed that one
another incredibly different than
anything we had taken on to this point
before incredibly different so now we're
just gonna head back and see what's in
store on Florida Levin thank you all so
much for checking out the video today if
you loved it please consider hitting
that subscribe button before you go and
I will talk to you again soon